alors vous le connaissez je reçois
maintenant il ya les clés et ses gains
le chef de l'orchestré métropolitain
maestro bonsoir bonsoir c'est pas tout à
fait votre genre de musique j'imagine
mais quand même la bonne musique des
bons artistes
ça fait partie de la même famille alors
oui je des goûts éclectiques
eh bien on se disait qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'artistes donc avait dû
peut-être ou qui songe à abandonner leur
carrière dans la musique parce que on
l'a la guilde je crois a fait un sondage
équité que plus de la moitié songes ou
envisagent de laisser tomber il y en a
près 20% qui ont déjà décidé de quitter
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique en
fait c'est que une crise comme celle
qu'on vient de vivre ben on est encore
dedans mais les douze derniers mois ça
ça nous met encore en face la fragilité
de notre milieu culturel la fragilité
des artistes
on a une aide au québec ici qui est très
appréciable et il faut être
reconnaissant il faut savoir être
reconnaissant quand on compare à
d'autres pays
mais cette aide là elle va plus souvent
aux institutions et les institutions et
leurs artistes c'est sûr alors des gens
comme un orchestre en politique on est
choyé meilleur d'un écosystème
montorieux des artistes pigiste ya des
artisans il ya des gens qui travaillent
dans les festivals l'été etc
c'est des années cd c'est un c'est une
richesse culturelle c'est un patrimoine
de gens qui ont des spécialités qui sont
formés et que c'est un effet
d'entraînement incroyable ce qui vient
de se passer et c'est ce qui me fait
main qui est témoin depuis le début et
qui m'a motivé à travailler comme je lé
fais pour essayer à ma propre façon mais
comme bien d'autres d'essayer de garder
son envie de plus posé parce que vous
avez travaillé beaucoup finalement
pendant la pandémie va rester créatif
son numérique
en fait comme quand on est un directeur
artistique quand on est un chef on est
comme une locomotive donc derrière soi
il ya plein de wagons et qui
si moi je mets pas l'épaule à la roue
avec mes équipes je suis pas tout seul
évidemment la superbe équipe du
métropolitain mais d'autres institutions
aussi c'est pour faire travailler les
gens autour et profiter du maximum des
opportunités qu'on nous a donnée dans le
milieu culturel ici au québec qui
étaient bien meilleures qu'ailleurs mais
justement vous venez de dire par le
numérique pour essayer de donner large
de l'argent aux gens mais aussi puis
j'écoutais dans cette magnifique
émission on parle beaucoup des services
et la musique l'art le théâtre la
littérature c'est un service alors on se
mettra pas à faire le débat sur
l'essentiel fanon j'oserais pas dire
qu'on est essentielle comme quelqu'un
qui fait donne des soins en fin de vie
décente pour nous les musiciens sont
tellement essentiel on n'a jamais
réalisé autant que il nous manquait vous
vous dites comme ça on voit cette
magnifique salle ici la salle vide ça ça
vient nous chercher parce que c'est
c'est ce qui nous manque pour que la
reste en vie mais en attendant ce qu'on
a fait c'est d'essayer de donner du
réconfort aux gens durant cette période
trouble de donner du réconfort que ce
soit en allant jouer dans les chu et
celle d où un même tout un chacun dans
sa quarantaine finalement si on avait
dit dans la quarantaine pendant
votre confinement vous êtes privés aussi
écouter la musique de regarder la
télévision d'avoir des scieries de lire
des romans donc dans ce sens là oui
c'est essentiel mais tout ça ça ne vit
qu'à cause des artistes et ça parfois
peut-être qu'on oublie ça prend des gens
derrière tout ça tout c'est tout ce
qu'on voit qui est même numérique ça
prend ça prend des gens il faut les
nourrir ces gens les folies les cultiver
en fait mais ça vous pensez que le
numérique savoir rester parce que
c'était quand même difficile son public
pour les artistes d'origine c'est très
difficile mais le numérique peut rester
et peut vivre seulement si leur vivant
reste c'est à dire que le contact avec
le public le fait de de performer
d'échangés ce moment magique qui a dans
une salle où que dans même dans un
cinéma quand on se met ensemble et qu'on
vit les mêmes émotions mais que dans une
salle de concert et une interaction qui
est loch
qui est irremplaçable et que le
numérique peut pas remplacer mais le
numérique
et ça ça a été une bonne chose a pu nous
aider à développer un outil de plus et
d'ailleurs on était du je trouve en tout
cas aux musiques classiques on était du
de pouvoir explorer ce médium pour
rejoindre un public qui vient pas
normalement dans nos salles et on s'est
rendu compte avec nos présentations en
tout cas lors qu'ils métropolitaine ont
rejoint un nouveau public avec nono
présentation numérique on a bien
l'intention de les garder mais ça ne
peut pas être que numérique c'est pas la
même magie et surtout le numérique peut
exister seulement si on est ensemble
mais on attend tous on espère tous qu'on
va pouvoir retourner voir des concerts
des spectacles du théâtre
mais est-ce qu'on veut reprendre comme
c'était avant d'après vous où le
numérique a changé un peu les choses
mais qu'est ce qui va changer est ce que
le monde de les arts de la scène va être
le même
je pense pas que le numérique est
l'ennemi pour reprendre comme c'était en
fait il n'ya pas d'ennemis je pense que
moi j'ai bon c'est sûr que je suis d'une
nature optimiste mais ce que je crois et
je sens l'envi du public de revenir dans
les salles
c'est sûr qu'il y aura une période de
crainte je vais l'appeler le crescendo
l'on est prêt n'a été pianissimo trop
longtemps j'attends le crescendo pour
qu'on puisse se rejoindre retrouver
notre public mais ce qui va changer et
j'espère pour le mieux c'est par exemple
ce qui est arrivé dans nos
programmations
on a dû les détruire ses programmations
parce que tout s'est écroulé d'un jour à
l'autre il ya un an et en reprogrammant
ça nous a donné l'opportunité d'ouvrir
et d'accélérer des conversations bien
nécessaire
j'ai envie même de dire qui était qui
aurait dû se passer depuis longtemps
quant à la diversité de nos
programmations représentativité à
l'inclusion on prend qui se font aussi
entre les formes d'art moi c'est ce qui
me motive les pompes à limur d'avoir des
collaborations entre le théâtre et les
orchestres les collaborations entre un
street artiste de rue et le num orist
d'avoir des collaborations comme ça
inter culturel et ça je pense que ça va
rester et je souhaite qu'on retourne
plus en arrière dans cette espèce de
productivité à tout prix il faut
produire tant de représentations de
théâtre parce qu'on doit et là oui c'est
une pression semaine pression puis la
routine s'installe alors là il y en a
plus de routine et on a vu ce qu'on a
perdu et je pense qu'on est peut-être je
souhaite en tout cas chic pour moi j'ai
eu l'impression que ça m'a permis de me
recentrer de revenir à l'essentiel
2 pourquoi l'art besoin de le coeur de
l'art a besoin de battre et c'est pour
refléter qui on est et pouvoir se parler
échanger et être le miroir de qui on est
d'être le miroir de l'autre aussi
et d'avoir cette inclusion lasser c'est
vraiment ce que je nous souhaite à
beaucoup d'artistes qui ont dit qu'ils
s'étaient sentis va vous voulez pas trop
en parler mais qui se sont senti un peu
exclu en disant on n'a pas été considéré
comme le travail essentiel mais
qu'est-ce qui va falloir faire pour que
justement nos artistes avaient parlé de
leur précarité qu'on a vu pendant cette
crise qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire
pour justement qu'il devienne plus
essentielles ces articles
mais d'abord il dirait que le statut de
l'artiste
c'est quand même un débat qu'on a dans
notre société depuis quelques temps et
c'est quelque chose qui n'existe plus en
europe
en fait c'est sûr que si on se compare
aux voisins du sud et moi en étant
responsable aussi oui du maître et de
philadephie ce beaucoup beaucoup plus
difficile cette précarité est encore
plus cruel je dirais mais en europe y
existe quand même des façons de
considérer l'artiste comme un certain
statut c'est à dire une façon de payer
l'artiste pour qu'ils puissent vivre
aussi de son art puisse créer alors le
plein de programmes on est presque là je
trouve au québec mais on n'a pas encore
trouvé un moyen de rejoindre et de
s'assurer de la pérennité des artistes
parce que l'exemple et l'analogie que
j'aime donner moi c'est par rapport à
l'édifice société neutre
la société combattit et dont on est fier
malgré ses défauts
c'est comme un édifice comme un édifice
avec des briques et la culture ce n'est
pas une brique
si le mortier entre les briques 6 qui
tient tout ça ensemble
la culture est partout c'est le reflet
de ce qui se passait dans cette reprise
qui s'amorce
moi c'est ce que je souhaite est
peut-être que c'est long on va voir
encore plus l'essentiel c'est l'art qui
veut nous aider à se sortir de la crise
c'est l'art qui va nous permettre cet
exutoire
cette façon de se rappeler ce qui s'est
passé dans ce sens jamais oublié d'avoir
des chanteuses qui trouvent des hymnes à
nous chanter d'avoir des nouveaux romans
des pièces de théâtre pour non seulement
documenté mais nous amener ailleurs
collectivement pour notre santé mentale
collective
oui on a tellement hâte unique n'existe
guère merci beaucoup d'être venus et
merci de m'avoir permis d'en parler au
nom des artistes nahd de vous revoir
présent sienne comme on dit et moi donc
et nous donc avec des sièges pleins on
l'espère merci beaucoup